[bluesy rock music playing]
♪ ♪
- So WebMD says I have colitis.
Turns out when I lost
all that weight,
I thought I was
getting healthier.
I was actually getting sick.
So now I can't have milk,
ice cream, cheese.
Can't have yogurt.
- Dairy.
- Yeah, exactly. Dairy.
Can't have it,
so Chrissy made me
a dairy-free dinner
last night.
It was actually pretty good.
God, I love her.
Honestly,
every day I wake up,
I'm so thankful
to have her.
When are you gonna
settle down, man?
- Can you help us settle a bet?
- Sure.
- Excuse me!
We're talking!
Move it along.
Thanks.
Seriously, man,
when are you gonna settle down?
It's amazing.
- Yeah, Tim, I do want
to meet somebody.
- Then what is stopping you?
- Hey, I like your shirt.
That color looks great
on you.
- Oh, so you just
interrupt people?
Is that your whole gig,
you interrupt folks?
We don't know
who you are.
Later, dude.
Seriously, why are you
not settling down?
- Because of you, Tim!
It's impossible
to meet girls around you.
- Okay, that's insane.
- Oh, yeah, sure.
Okay, I'm insane, then.
- Suit yourself, man.
Giving you advice.
What if he's right?
What if he is insane
and I'm just a figment
of his imagination?
[chuckles] Oh, man.
[stomach growls]